feeling very Icelandic I'm looking at
ice there's a landline in my room and
I'm not opposed to dick
hi my name is grace helbig if you don't
know and I know your life is different
now I didn't want people doing these
very honest QA
you're on YouTube so I thought why not
I've been on the internet for it now
seven eight years something like that so
why not start telling you the truth
about me I'm sure a lot of what you
might hear in these answers are things
that I've said another video through my
books around the podcast or whatever but
hey let's talk about the weird awkward
stuff in an upward Q&A went on Twitter
and asked you guys for questions using
the hashtag to ask grace and do you all
work for ups because you guys really
delivered let's just do this okay so
let's just jump right in when you lose
your virginity
the real easy question to start off with
I wrote about this moment we didn't read
it
already I've talked about it numerous
times in videos but for those of you
that do not know I lost my virginity
when I was 18 years old I was a freshman
in college a guy that I was sort of
dating on the indoor track team asked me
on a date for Valentine's Day I was so
excited I've never been on like an
official date before so into Macy's and
I got myself closed avril lavigne
looking skirt was even like a little
chain on it she was really cute at that
time baby she wasn't cute at that time
but I just liked her aesthetic and
thought she was cool and she and I share
the same birthday and he took me to a
macaroni grill which if you're not
familiar is a chain Kylian restaurant in
which they give you crayons and you can
draw and I thought oh my god here am i
right let's do this and by this I mean
sex and it was not good we dated for two
years though oh the places you can go
when you give a girl in a novel Libyan
skirt the opportunity to draw on the
tablecloth very clean you've done in
public there's a couple things of course
I'm making YouTube videos I was doing a
lot of odd jobs and a lot of shoots one
of my first like paid acting gigs was
for truTV I worked as an assistant to a
process server a process server someone
that serves people legal papers like
divorce papers or papers warnings of
swings and things like that so there was
this like pseudo reality television show
on truTV about this process
servername Byron and it's been going on
for seasons and Byron was a real life
process server in real life they brought
me in as this new storyline as is like
dick share head assisted I was just like
early and like totally and capable they
would set up scenarios all around
Manhattan and New Jersey and then we
just have to improvise out these
scenarios and they always turned into
like crazy elaborate physical things one
was in a salon in Harlem where we had to
serve the salon owner papers and he
ended up getting burned on a curling
iron and throwing like talcum powder
everywhere
one oh the pizza shelf in New Jersey and
then just throwing pizza dough in my
hair and pouring lasagna on her car
believe me what line was we had to serve
this like high-profile hedge fund dude
while was jogging in Central Park and I
jog along with him and then Byron and
him got into an altercation and the
security guards came out of nowhere and
like lifted me up and carried me away it
was so you have to do these stunts in
public and let them play out for like
15-20 minutes while the public watch and
then we'd have to do them again and
sometimes a third time and it was some
of the most embarrassing stuff I did but
you know I was really dedicated to the
art of improvisation and acting and they
really wanted to make it big work write
about being a youtuber obviously there's
a billion tremendous things about being
a youtuber but one of the worst parts
about being a youtuber just being in the
creative world in general is comparing
yourself to other people I struggle with
that a lot I sometimes get into really
negative head spaces because it's so
easy to comparing numbers and to compare
statistics and to wonder why you aren't
doing as well as other people and that
is a very very terrible isolating and
discouraging thought process that I have
to learn to shake for myself because it
gets you nowhere just waste your time so
instead focus on the things you can
control and Kendu that's not me saying
that to you it's more me saying that to
myself
so dude you're just here for that Thanks
yes oh you're a teenage moment story I
think I've told this story before too
again when I was in high school I worked
at Chili's my favorite restaurant
so I'd already peeked in my career
endeavors at that point I was a hostess
and I had a crush on one of the Busboys
and afterward they used to go to this
billiards or like pool bar where they
would smoke and play pool and so my
friends and I went with them one night
and I lied to my mom instead I was
sleeping at my friend's house and really
I was trying to stay out and hang out
with these Busboys from the restaurant I
did actually end up sleeping at my
friend's house but they all went home I
tried to stay later and like nothing was
going to happen with this boy and
nothing did happen so I walk to my car
to leave and I was leaving the parking
lot there was a light and the car up and
stuff like I was trying to pull up next
to the car so I could make a left-hand
turn and when I pull it back to the car
I have no spatial awareness
I'm the worst driver wasn't drinking it
all this night my car that called the ox
at the time a 97 Dodge Intrepid these
are not important details but it paints
a picture the side view window on the
right passenger side not into this car
side view window and knocked it off
immediately I didn't know what to do and
the car got right behind me and it was
this total South Jersey bro dude tatted
up with two very minimally clothes women
in the car and the guy thought I was a
guy and so he just starts raging out if
they're screaming at me and group works
for the wolf who don't get that
apartment broad like romantic guy I
don't know what to do the light's still
red it hasn't changed I can't drive away
he gets up to my window as if he's going
to rip me out of the car and yes then
they sees that I'm like a little scared
child I think I was 16 or 17 years old
and a little scared girl staring back at
him like tears in her eyes and he's like
oh you I I'm sorry I thought I thought
you were gay I'm so sorry
I could pop this back into place to
watch I'll pop it back into place a just
literally popping windows back into
place got in a car and drove away it all
happened so quick I was so terrified and
when he has driven away I finally look
down and I pissed
but dances a lot of your questions that
you guys tweeted at me about when the
last time was I full-on piss my pants
and I think that was it Oh
how many men's are coming up in this
awkward Q&A series we compliment - do
they make you uncomfortable compliments
make me uncomfortable but I'm learning
to take them better works relieve you
when you're suddenly stuck by your
period while in public ooh get thee to a
toilet and make thee a tampon out of
toilet paper until you can get yourself
a real tampon or a pad or whatever you
need to do that's my piece of advice
that's a fun you know a little mental
game for yourself if you're really bored
in a place just look around and think
what could be a tampon what you're
asking about dating oh I think the worst
thing about dating is finding someone
that you're very attracted to that kind
of checks off all the boxes of person
that you want to investigate more as a
potential situation and then finding out
that they're unavailable and it's so
heart good and gets all the guts out of
your heart are we doing another film
this year hopefully yes and hopefully
more than one but I'll say about that
when we ought to make a video of you
trying to see if food lifehacks really
work or not yeah definitely if that's
something you guys want to see let me
know leave a comment down below should I
do a food act video should I jump on
that bandwagon I'm really good at
jumping I did triple jump when I was in
high school track and field
what's your favorite movie much TV
project you've done so far we've done so
many awesome project one of my favorites
that almost I didn't get as much
promotion as I was hoping it would get
was a little diner girl that Hannah Hart
and I did I believe it's still in full
screen I think I still watch it on
iTunes
I loved that project so so much it was
such a joy to film and so I you guys
haven't checked it out please do you can
crush i refresh I have a big boner for
that friend group that is Patty and
Patty and zane and heath as liza and
davis and those kids i think that
they're really fun and i just wish they
would ask me to hang out and get drunk
with them that so desperate sounding
what are your most awkward dream
recently i dreamt twice to suffer james
in one night then I was just chewing
glass I was getting stuck in my teeth
and I couldn't get out of my tea
like corn a sharp painful corn when we
clean ex-boyfriends do you ever think
well meth would have been a smarter bad
decision no I think almac boyfriend's
have been in my life for a very
important reason as maybe cheesy as it
sounds but I like to look back fondly on
the relationships I've had and really
try to process what I gained from them
and how I've grown since them and what
I've learned at old because that sounds
really healthy weirdest thing you've
woken up to you after a particularly
drunk night I woke enough to my keys in
my refrigerator
looking up there's so many different
food combinations many different clothes
mine strewn everywhere onesies that I
started try on by myself I guess are the
fun little treasures and you're getting
bored or frustrated with YouTube
sometimes I am it's only normal that you
would get bored or frustrated or burnout
or worn out by a thing you're doing
especially after seven or eight years of
doing it I think I'm in a little bit of
a valley and I'm trying to get up to a
peak how do I get up to a peak you guys
are going to work on some quick base
thumbnails and titles calf damnit I
would ever bring anything awkward to
show-and-tell at school in kindergarten
I brought my [ __ ] my family I just got
a kitten a name taker and I brought it
to show and tell ok that's it for this
awkward Q&A I hope this is fun for you
guys if you like this kind of video let
me know because this is I don't know
kind of therapeutic and kind of fun to
make so maybe I'll make more just video
a thumbs up if you like it and you want
more awkward Q&A from me you're awkward
older sister Grace and helping the first
oh don't forget to subscribe to the
future general because that's how I know
that people want to see things I make
videos Monday Wednesday and Friday
sometimes other than that I don't sell
similar to what you ask and not to deep
describe your worst sexual experience in
three words or phrases did you fart